Last week we spent a lot
of time dealing with high
electoral politics,
canvassing the career of
Jesse Jackson, scooting past
Ronald Reagan's and George
Bush's and--presidencies
and the campaign,
the Bush-Dukakis
campaign, for,
you know, the Willie
Horton ad and the way,
and the way in which
racial conversations become
subverted into
something else,
although still remaining
quite racial in the context
of 1990s
politics, and something,
a process that
began decades earlier,
certainly, with the
civil rights successes or
excesses, depending on one's
politics. Much of last
week's themes were dealing
with the submergence of
racial discourse and also
the racialization of crime,
and also the further
development of coalition
politics as we move to a
much more racially and
ethnically, ethnically mixed
society. Now in the last
two lectures of the
course--I can't believe
we're already here, but we
are--I want to continue with
my focus on post-civil
rights presidencies and
public policies, examining
in particular how race
affected public policy and
how cultural symbols still
do so many, so much heavy
lifting for a much more
complicated real world in
which we all live. Some of
the themes of this
week are deal--are,
are discussions relating
to the presumptions of the
permanence of
civil rights changes,
and the presumptions of the
goals of civil rights. You
know, what is the underlying
presumption of integration?
What is "the race" and
who speaks for "the race"?
These are themes you're
going to pick up in your
reading,
certainly. There will be,
as you've become accustomed
already in this course,
overlapping as far as
chronology as well as
policy, court cases,
and cultural symbols,
all operating at the same
time in overlapping ways.
So we left off really in
George Bush's presidency.
I want to pick up in 1992
with Bill Clinton being
elected to the office.
He's elected with a,
a--embodying great
Democratic promise. I mean,
this is after twelve years
of Republicans in control of
the White House
and, you know,
a generation of, of younger
people not ever knowing a
Democrat in the White
House. Bill Clinton comes
in with an incredible
sense of charisma,
and it's really, it's
really quite astonishing,
and a clear natural talent
to speak to black Americans
in a voice that black
Americans can recognize.
And for African America, it
becomes a moment of great
hope in terms of what the
potential--the future might
hold.
Clinton makes
a lot of noise,
and it turns out to
be noise in many ways,
about his commitment to
making a cabinet and a White
House
administration that, quote,
"looked like America." This
is one of his phrases during
the period. Making his
administration look like
America runs into a problem,
when he nominates to the
position of Assistant
Secretary of Civil Rights
Professor of Law at the
University of Pennsylvania
at the time named Lani
Guinier. During this moment
in the early years of
the Clinton presidency,
or when he was
president-elect,
being a friend of
Bill, an "F.O.B.,
was a big deal. If you
were a friend of Bill with
all of his connections
and his wife's connections,
you might have a real in to
becoming part of the White
House administration.
Lani, Lani Guinier is
one of these individuals,
goes, you know, goes back
to law school days with the
Clintons. Guinier had been
an advocate for years in,
in law review articles of
something called "cumulative
voting," a process that
allowed for greater interest
group representation.
Something along the lines,
and I'm being
verycrude about it,
if there are ten candidates
running for an office,
you don't just get one vote
under cumulative voting.
You have ten votes you
spread along the ten
candidates. Maybe
on a certain issue,
Candidate A really
represents your views. You
want to give that
person five votes. And on a
certain issue Candidate--I
don't know if I did A or B
or one or two--another
candidate represents a lot
of your opinions, so you
want to give that person
three votes.
It's actually a way of
hyper-democratizing who gets
represent--represented in
office. It's a process,
moreover, and
this is important,
that the Reagan and Bush
Justice Departments had
sanctioned in over three
dozen instances. So it
is--it was an
embrace of democracy,
letting the
little person have a,
a chance to say something,
and it was a process that
had been embraced by
Republican-nominated or
controlled
Department of Justice.
However, Bill Clinton,
as much as he excited the
Democratic, liberal base,
he infuriated a conservative
base, and that conservative
base went into attack mode.
There'd been a phrase that
had been really popularized
during Ronald
Reagan's presidency,
and that's this, the phrase
"the spin doctor." Someone
who comes in, who
doctors up the message,
spins it around, and turns
it into something quite
different. Lani
Guinier is tagged,
because of her
cumulative voting ideology,
as being a "quota queen" by
conservative media types.
She's a "quota queen." Now
what's the big deal with the
phrase? The phrase
actually is very clever,
because it links to two
different problems in the
American present to the
American past. One is this
direct connotation
of the welfare queen,
which is a, an, a
catchphrase of the
eighties. Welfare queens
were used as individuals,
I mean propped up as
individuals who were
bringing down the American
social network and really a
blight on the American
economy. And these were
depicted as
women, of course,
they were queens,
overwhelmingly African
American, although most
welfare recipients are not
African American,
but people who,
who capitalized upon the
system and took advantage of
it; that under the logic
of welfare at the time,
the more children you had,
the more aid you received.
Now the story's much
more complicated than this,
but the, the construction
of the image was that the
welfare queen was the person
responsible for being a real
drain on the system.
So Guinier's politics or
ideology is
linked to excess,
excess of the state with the
welfare queen ideology. But
the quota part's also
important. That links back
earlier than the
Reagan presidency,
by linking it to quotas,
something that had come up
in the Supreme Court case in
Bakke versus the Regents of
the University
of California,
decided in 1978. The
Supreme Court case had said
that quotas were
unconstitutional. Now
Bakke, just in a
super quick nutshell,
Allan Bakke, white man,
sues--applies for University
of California,
Davis medical school,
isn't admitted. And he
discovers through his
research that
according to scores,
in terms of what scores
people received on the MCAT,
that African American/Latino
applicants got in who scored
lower than he did. And then
he also discovered that UC
Davis, in an attempt to
diversify its student body,
had created a set-aside
program that had quotas,
that--and I'm making the
numbers up here--that "we're
going to admit up to
twenty, or at minimum
twenty"--again,
I don't--the,
the actual terminology
is not important right
now--"African
American/Latino medical
students into UC Davis, with
a goal of diversifying our
population." The Supreme
Court weighs in in 1978
saying that such
set-aside programs,
mandated numbers,
were unconstitutional.
Okay, there it
is. I had mute on,
I'm sorry. That you cannot
just pick a number and say
that that's okay. So
Guinier is linked to the
excesses of welfare reform
or welfare policies in the
1980s, the excesses of
civil rights ideology,
trying to diversify
America through quotas,
through the 1970s, decided
in seventy-eight. And
people started
attacking her,
politicians, activists.
Clinton famously takes
her--says he's going to take
a retreat to Camp David and
takes her, her law review
articles. He's going to
think about it. And he
comes back from Camp David
saying, you know, "I've
looked at this thing more
carefully, and, you know,
her views are not in line
with the kind of politics
that I want to practice."
And Clinton
withdraws the nomination,
even when his
attorney general,
Janet Reno, said that
Guinier deserved the right
to at least present her
actual views. The views had
been misappropriated. Black
liberals felt cheated by
Clinton as he made a clear
move to the center. They
felt he was caving in to
conservative politicians and
activists.
And whether he
was or he wasn't,
Clinton does--I mean on
that case with Lani Guinier,
Clinton does make a
very clear move to take up
Reagan's strategy of
capture--Reagan captured
the, the moderate
Democrat who was fed up and
frustrated, and brought them
over to the Republican camp;
Clinton went to take them
back. He wanted to capture
the middle ground
voters in America,
which, as the politics in
this country become more
conservative, meant a
dramatic turn or a shift to
the right. Now, in
part, liberals are concerned
because they see Clinton's
decision as part of a
general move away from
substantive embrace of civil
rights ideologies and
victories of the late
1960s--of the 1960s.
Clinton, it soon seemed
to these liberals and
activists, was more
willing, more than willing,
to cede ground to
conservatives in order to
steal some of their
thunder. In fact,
you, you'd hear activists
during the 1990s being
frustrated, because Clinton
was saying all these things,
"all these
things" in quotes,
that Republicans had
been talking about for the
longest time, but claiming
credit for them. It was a
massive stroke of, of
political leadership,
even though it certainly
frustrated to no end
conservatives and
liberals. Now Clinton,
although an individual
who had his weaknesses,
he certainly had
incredible strengths,
and he understood the
ability--he had the ability
to read the tenor of the
times. It's an era of
repositioning on the
national scene against the
so-called excesses of the
1960s. In this course,
I spend a lot of time
talking about look--taking a
critical eye, looking at
southern states and their,
their policies, states'
versus federal rights,
for example. And while
other states still have,
or still are quite rich with
complications in terms of
racial politics, I want
to turn my attention for,
for a little bit to the
West. This is actually a,
a structural
flaw in the course,
because there's so much
material focusing on the
Southeast. This is a
national problem. For the
moment, we'll just
focus on the West. It's in
California in the
1990s--It's in California in
the 1990s where America
sees a new frontier in race
politics, and this is
something that grabs the
attention of the nation.
I mean, California does
take up a lot of space.
It grabs the attention of
the nation and also ends up
writing a cru--a, a, an
interesting chapter in
Clinton's race politics.
I want to talk now about
propos--two propositions
in the 1990s. One is
Proposition 187,
called "Save Our State,
and the second is
Proposition 209,
called the "California Civil
Rights Initiative." In
1994--and by the way, I'm
sorry. For those who don't
know, California has this
allegedly super democratic
process of changing,
changing the state
constitution, that if the
citizens of the state garner
enough signatures, and
they float a proposition to
change the
state constitution,
they can act with--they
can enact changes to the
constitution. Now it seems
democratic on its surf--on
its face, but it's actually
been hijacked--I don't know
when that started, probably
from the beginning--by very
strong corporate interest
and political activist
interest on all sides of
the political spectrum,
that have the resources
to hire people to gather
signatures. Proposition 187
certainly embodied this kind
of organizing logic.
Again, it's called "Save Our
State." It's a proposition
heavily supported by then
Governor of
California Pete Wilson,
someone who'd been a
moderate Republican,
who turns aggressively
conservative as he
be--begins to put
out--to cast an eye on a
presidential campaign, a
campaign that ultimately
flops miserably. Everybody
knows that race and economic
issues are
politically divisive,
and that way they can be
extremely effective. This
is what Wilson
identifies in Prop.
187 and sees it as a way to
put his name on the national
screen.
Proposition 187 focused
on social services. 187
ended--if, if it
were put--made law,
would end public
social services,
would end health
services and education for
undoc--undocumented
immigrants,
illegal aliens, illegal
aliens. So it's ending the
social
network--the safety net,
excuse me, and education for
undocumented immigrants.
And it was about addressing
a fiscal crisis in
healthcare in the state.
It was a very real crisis,
but it was also
cast in racial light.
There was a controversial ad
that showed nighttime border
crossers. Now they're
non-racialized. No one ever
mentions their race,
the advertiser doesn't,
but everybody knows that
these are Mexicans crossing
the border at
night. And these unnamed,
un-raced individuals are
depicted in the ad as a
pestilent scourge, scourge,
like rats invading the
house; that they are
coming into our state,
they are invading it,
they're taking it over. 187
does pass.
"Let's save our state,
by God," but it's caught up
in litigation and ultimately
killed when the moderate
Democrat Grey Davis now the
become--now the
governor of California,
dismisses it in
1999. But it takes up,
you know, the
second half of the,
the decade as far as
political energy in the
state of California.
At the same time, Prop 187
is winding its way through
the litigation process,
California starts debating
another proposition,
this one in two--in 1996,
Prop.
209, the "California Civil
Rights Initiative." Now the
"California Civil
Rights Initiative" ends
discrimination against and
preferential treatment for
any individual or
groups based on race,
sex, color, ethnicity, or
national origin. So it ends
discrimination against
individuals or groups,
based on race, sex,
color, ethnicity,
or national
origin. This is,
you know, something very
much in the tradition of the
civil rights heritage, of
course. But it also kills
preferential treatment for
the same groups. It is an
anti-affirmative action
proposition. As Prop.
209 is garnering
its votes, you have,
in the University of
California system,
a series of
faculty senate votes,
you know, for or
against the proposition,
and a, and a state prop--a
state law that's being
changed that's going to end
affirmative action in the UC
system, regardless
of what California,
excuse me, what Prop.
209 does. Affirmative
action's killed in the UC
system. The numbers of
minorities plummet overnight
in the flagship
schools, like UC Berkeley,
UCLA, UC San Diego.
I was teaching at UC
San Diego at the time,
which did--never did have
a large African American
population, student
population. It's around two
and a half
percent. Within one year,
it's cut in half to
one and a half percent.
You have at UCLA and, and
Cal tremendous drops in
numbers of African
American students in,
in the college and also in
places like the law school.
Now what's really important
about the "California Civil
Rights Initiative" and
the anti-affirmative action
initiatives in the
state is that--well,
a couple of
different things. There's a
hyper-focus on race.
People are talking about,
you know, affirmative action
and "it's going to eliminate
the black and brown presence
on campuses. It's going to
eliminate the chance for
black and brown people to,
to have an equal opportunity
to get certain jobs." But
the group that it affected
the most was white women.
Since affirmative action
became a federal policy,
white women have
overwhelmingly been the
group that benefited the
most from affirmative action
policies, and they would be
the group most negatively
affected. And yet that
discourse is written out of
the conversation in
California. Also,
at the same
time, there's a T.V.
ad appears. It
runs for one day,
just like the
Willie Horton ad,
ad runs just a couple of
times in a day. The T.V.
ad runs for one day that
claims that Martin Luther
King would have
supported Proposition 209,
taking a few lines from
his famous speeches and
misrepresenting
them. In fact,
King had gone on the
record saying that he was in
support of these minority
set-aside programs then,
soon to be called
affirmative action
programs. Jesse Jackson
is horrified that these two
professors at
Berkeley, I believe,
who organized this ad
campaign were the ones
behind the logic of the
"California Civil Rights
Initiative," that they would
misappropriate King in that
way. They
weren't the first,
and they
wouldn't be the last,
but it's an
important sort of legacy,
or wrestling with the memory
of who people like King
were. Then you have the
issue of the name itself.
It's the "California Civil
Rights Initiative." In our
post-civil rights age, when
we are all enlightened on
racial issues, so our
general feeling goes,
who's going to be against
civil rights? People don't
want to be against civil
rights. They don't want to
be considered racist, after
all. And so when people go
into the ballot
booth, the election booth,
and vote, it turns out
Calif--Proposition 209,
the "California Civ--Civil
Rights Initiative,
essentially sails through,
and it enjoys a majority of
African American support,
enjoys a major--majority of
support from white women,
and I believe--I'm just,
I don't have my notes on
this issue in front of me,
so I'm not going to
vouch for it for certain,
but I think it receives a
majority of Mexican American
support as well.
If not a majority,
the numbers are high. When
asked about these issues,
white women responded that
they didn't realize that the
civ--civil rights initiative
would actually--was a vote
against their own
self-interest. African
Americans made it clear,
"We're for civil rights."
They hadn't read the
proposition. And Mexican
Americans supported it as
well for curious reasons.
They support civil rights,
but they also saw this way
of, of supporting this
platform as a way to
"Americanize" themselves,
even though they already had
American citizenship
status. So what--taking all
of these things together,
what does it actually lead
us to? It leads us to a
point where we are today,
frankly, of a general
dumbing down of discourse in
politics and
media about race,
and a gen--general
laziness as well amongst the
electorate when it comes
to thinking about these
things. Now it doesn't help
this process when you have
people making editorial
decisions that play to our
low--lowest common
denominator. And this
really is a theme of the
American political thought,
social and cultural thought,
of the last twenty or thirty
years, lowest common
denominator does a really
great job of appearing
first. So it doesn't help
us become more astute
thinkers about race and
citizenship and belonging
in politics when you have
people making editorial
decisions that capitalize
upon racialized notions
of blacks as criminal,
for instance. Just, just
take this--this is all the
attention that I'm
going to pay to the O.J.
Simpson case, although
it captivates the United
States. The picture you see
on your left is the picture
that ran in Time
magazine of O.J.
Simpson. The actual picture
is the one on the right.
Now people know what O.J.
Simpson looks like, okay,
and this is not a poor--I
mean, it's, it's, it's
not a high-quality image,
but it's not appearing
darker because it's being
projected. That
is a darkened,
clearly darkened,
picture of O.J.
Simpson. So
when the cover ran,
people were like, "That
seems a little--I don't
think O.J.'s that dark."
And then someone got a hold
of the actual print from the
mug shot. People were up in
arms.
"What are you
doing?" The response was,
"Well, by Photoshopping
things a little bit,
it made the image
pop." That was the quote,
"it made the image pop." It
was a better image. As if
anybody needed to have
a better image of O.J.
Simpson. It wasn't
like he was a mystery,
and no matter what you felt
about what he did or didn't
do, you're still going
to buy the magazine cover
whether you're going to
have a light image or a dark
image of O.J.
Simpson. The young
editor, photographic editor,
wasn't around much
longer, I believe,
at Time, but he was probably
taking the fall for some
other editorial
decision. Anyway,
our national discourse
is one that's become
increasingly impoverished,
and we're still in that
moment in our leisurely
"post-racial" today. But
it's in this
state of affairs,
getting back to Clinton now,
with Proposition "Save Our
State," Proposition
"California Civil Rights
Initiative," O.J.
Simpson in that
bizarre moment,
it's in this state of
affairs that Bill Clinton
travels to
University of California,
San Diego for its
graduation ceremony in 1997,
and while there, announces a
new presidential initiative,
"a National
Dialogue on Race,
or "the One America,"
or "the President's Race
Initiative," or "a National
Conversation on Race." It
had all these different
titles. It was all the same
thing. Clinton wanted to do
something really--many of us
thought that was really
astonishing. Recognizing
that there was an
impoverished state of affair
in our national conversation
about race--this is a person
who grows up in the South,
grows up around African
Americans, can speak in a
vernacular diction that was
reminiscent, or
sounded familiar to African
Americans. This is a person
who got black America and
was tremendously popular
amongst black Americans,
even despite Lani Guinier
and other missteps along the
way. People thought, "Wow,
Clinton's actually going to
do something here." He is
better positioned than any
other President since Jimmy
Carter to do this. The idea
is, we're going to have town
hall meetings all across the
country where members
of Clinton's Blue Ribbon
Committee, chaired by the
late historian John Hope
Franklin, path breaking
historian of many--for many
reasons but, most famously,
for breaking so many color
lines as a black historian.
Now you had these town hall
meetings across the country
to talk about our current
conversation about race. A
lot of really smart people
on this committee; it
seemed like a moment of real
promise. And the moment
kind of implodes right away
when the commission comes
together to sort of organize
itself and Angela Oh, a
Korean attorney in Los
Angeles, tremendously strong
record when it comes to
civil rights law, she
clashes immediately with
John Hope Franklin. She has
an incredibly strong record
on civil rights
activism and scholarship,
and the clash was
about how, in 1997,
'98, should America talk
about race? Franklin was
saying, "You must start with
slavery. Everything comes
from that, that
everything--every kind of
conversation comes with
that." Angela Oh says,
"You start from slavery,
you are eliminating from the
conversation
millions, Chinese,
Japanese, and Koreans and
people from other different
parts of the world who
don't have part of that
experience." And
in so many ways,
they're both exactly right,
so how do you resolve this?
Well, it turns out you
don't. The commission
effectively becomes
a, a dead letter,
had a few conversations.
Nothing much comes of it.
Clinton's
philandering, his denial,
and his impeachment, serves
as a profound distraction
and sinks his second term.
So the conversation becomes
a muted conversation, muted
by the impeachment trial if
nothing else. Clinton's
impeachment trial was not
the only important court
case of the nineties. And I
want to spend what time I
have left talking about some
of these court cases,
because it brings us
really--it brings us to a
campus. It brings us to our
fairly current moment. I
want to talk about four
court cases, three from the
1990s and one from 2003.
Most of them are
Supreme Court cases,
not all of them though.
The first one is Shaw v.
Reno, v.
Reno, against the attorney
general of the United
States, Janet Reno, and it
involved redistricting in
North Carolina,
congressional districts.
The federal government
required North Carolina,
the state, the legislature,
to create another district
that would guarantee a black
majority. North Carolina's
not an unusual southern
state with large black
populations, but
also clustered black
populations. And it wasn't
unusual among southern
states in that districts
were set up in such a way
that the black vote
was, was watered down,
thinned out. The
federal government,
the federal government
said, "North Carolina,
you need to get
your act together.
You need to create
another district that will
have--create the chance
to elect a black person in
office--put a black person
in office. We need a black
majority district." It
would be the new twelfth
district in North Carolina.
The district was formed, and
then a suit was brought by
those who felt the district
was a result of racial
gerrymandering.
Racial gerrymandering,
in this case, in support
of an African American
political presence. Racial
gerrymandering had always
been trying to eliminate a
black political presence,
in talking about black-white
issues. Now there are
several key issues that come
up in the decision in Shaw
v.
Reno. It was decided in
1993. One key issue is that
race is now a suspect
category. You know,
there was a slide a,
a little while ago,
I, I, I realized I, I left
it a little bit too early
in, in Bakke. Actually, let
me just--one point I forgot
to mention that's very
important right now: quotas
cannot be
considered in application,
but race can be considered
as one of the key factors in
admissions. So
Bakke's point,
one of the
things Bakke does,
he says, "We can think about
race when it comes to sort
of adjudicating the limits,
the parameters of racial
belonging." All right, just
keep that fact in mind. In
Shaw v.
Reno, the Supreme Court says
race is a suspect category.
"We've come a long way since
the challenges of the 1960s
and we need to think a
little more carefully about
when race is used." The
Voting Rights Act says that
people had to consider
issues of race when setting
up jurisdictions, and Shaw
says you just can't. So
Shaw starts to chip away at
the Voting Rights Act. And
it comes up with a
resolution: that race cannot
be the predominant factor
in deciding something like
voting districts, but it can
be considered. So this is
something in line with Bakke
but a little bit different.
Race can be considered but
can't be the predominant
factor; it is a suspect
category. And this is the
most important phrase:
there must be a compelling
government interest to
justify considering race.
So Shaw v.
Reno is really
asking, "How do we,
how do we take race into
consideration when we're
setting up public policy?"
It challenges the Voting
Rights Act of '65, so it's
chipping away at part of
it. There must be a
compelling government
interest. Now this is
the twelfth district,
I'm going to show you in a
second. And I'll confess,
I remember there was
a, there was a recent
resolution on this
last year about--it,
it came back again, I
confess I don't even recall
what the decision was, but
in '93 this is what people
were fighting against, the
twelfth district. See it
right there, that little
thing? Certainly a suspect
shape. I mean, districts
are always weird looking
anyway, following
rivers or sort of,
census tracts. District 12,
and it's actually thicker
here on the map
than it is in reality,
in the proposal, because
sometimes it just ran along
the highway. There's
no people living on the
highway. So it would go
from one black neighborhood
to another black
neighborhood. Now the
supposition of course is
that black folks will vote
for black
people. And that's,
that's something you
can talk about in your
discussion section. That's
a whole other kind of thorny
briar patch of
presumptions. So North
Carolina's proposed 12th
Congressional District,
it certainly looks awfully
strange. Going forward,
1995, Adarand v.
Peña. It's a case
in Colorado. Adarand
Construction versus
Peña, who's the secretary of
agri--transportation,
excuse me.
Up to this point, federal
agencies had given financial
incentives to those
contractors who hire
minority-controlled
subcontractors. So if you
want to build
something, and you're a,
say a contractor, I get a
bonus if I start looking for
minority-owned firms to help
do some of the work that I'm
supporting. And in
this particular case,
Adarand, a white-owned
construction firm,
submitted the lowest bid on
a contract for a highway,
but not, but did not get the
contract. The contract went
instead to a minority-owned
firm. So the Supreme Court
holds, the Supreme Court
holds that race can only be
used if there's a
compelling interest,
that builds off of Shaw v.
Reno, and then that the
government agency using
racial distribution must do
so under strict scrutiny,
another one of these
great Supreme Court phrases,
and it must be used in a
narrowly tailored way.
Compelling
interest, strict scrutiny,
narrowly tailored. What
you have in Adarand v.
Peña is again a narrowing of
the option to use race. You
got a incred--you have to
have an incredibly strong
case if you're
going to press a,
quote, "racial iss--issue"
and hope to have it
succeed. 1996,
state of Texas,
it's not a
Supreme Court case.
In Hopwood v.
Texas, the University of
Texas law school had been
aiming, a tradition of
aiming to admit a class that
looked like Texas. And
it actually changed its
admission formula to
benefit black and Latino
applicants. Cheryl
Hopwood, the plaintiff,
is one of four
people, all white,
who were denied admission
and then sued. The district
court sides with the
University of Texas,
saying they can set their
own admissions policy. They
haven't offended the
logic that was announced in
Bakke. The appeals court
took the plaintiffs' side
and in Hopwood, it says race
cannot be used as a plus
factor in the consideration
of applications. So Texas
didn't use quotas.
That's unconstitutional,
can't do it. But it
did say--you know,
I'm making up the numbers
in the schematic--if one
hundred points is what you
need to get admitted to the
University of
Texas law school,
if you're African American,
we're going to give you ten
more points. It helps boost
your score. And this is
actually a practice used by
many universities across the
country. I
know it's u--used,
used by the University of
California--they gave a bump
up to those
from historically
underrepresented groups.
It also gave a bump up for
veterans, and it gave
a bump up for other,
other populations as well.
But it was racial and ethnic
minorities who become the
focus of this excess. So if
you take Bakke as
the foundation,
you add Shaw v.
Reno, you take
Adarand versus Peña,
you take
Hopwood versus Texas,
you have a situation where
the very premise of Bakke,
which eliminated quotas
but said race could be used,
so it supported
affirmative action,
the premise of Bakke is
being stripped away. The
Voting Rights Act is being
narrowed in terms of how it
can be applied, and now
sort of ground zero for the
debate is university
admissions policies. This
is why the stakes were
so high in 2003 at the
University of Michigan.
In 1997, in 1997, Barbara
Grutter had applied to the
University of Michigan
law school and been denied
admission. The law school
freely admitted that it used
race in its admission as
a compelling interest to
achieve diversity. It used
that word that they knew
was--I mean, it's law
school. Compelling interest
is actually--that would
survive a litmus test,
so they felt. But
the question was,
does the University of
Michigan law school,
did its use of preferences
in student admissions
violate the equal protection
clause of the Fourteenth
Amendment or the Civil
Rights Act of '64? These
were the questions before
the court. Now I said
1997. This thing is
bouncing around until the
court decides it in 2003.
The lead-up to the Supreme
Court decision was
really quite fascinating,
because it tells a story of
our contemporary political
and capital--corporate
culture as it,
as it comes to affirmative
action. You have friends of
the court, petitions being
filed by a whole bunch of
people, and you have a
really fascinating coalition
being formed by corporate
interests and retired
military generals, that if
one takes a stereotype in
mind, they think, "well
these are very conservative
populations." These are the
groups that were very much
in favor of University
of Michigan's admissions
policy, very much in
favor of affirmative action,
the military actually being
one of the great places for
diversifying management
structures. I'm not saying
it's perfect; no place is.
But the military had done
more than many other
institutions to diversify
itself over the course of
the previous forty years.
And
corporations recognizing,
if you go back
to Jesse Jackson,
and his Operation PUSH, and
his boycotts of companies
like Coca-Cola
and Anheuser-Busch,
corporations recognizing,
"We need to have a pool of
talent that we can tap into
for management positions,
so we can tap into markets
and make more money." This
is what the corporations
were trying to do,
of course. "We need to
preserve affirmative action
policies, as long as
there aren't quotas,
wherever we can find them."
George Bush White House
comes out in support of
the plaintiffs. The Supreme
Court weighs in, and it
has a mixed answer. People
didn't know what was going
to happen. The mixed answer
is that student body
diversity is a compelling
state interest in the
context of university
admissions, of
university admissions. It's
compelling. Race can
therefore be a factor in
consideration of
the application,
as long as its use is
narrowly tailored. So you
see, you know, it's building
on the language of the court
cases I was already talking
about. It reaffirms,
therefore--Grutter v.
Bollinger reaffirms Bakke,
maintains a narrow framework
in which to understand
Bakke. But then Sandra Day
O'Connor says, and does
something rather unusual
that she's since
distanced herself from,
she goes, "You know, we
need this now." You know,
one of the issues
with conservatives,
and this is something that,
that--oh I just drew a blank
on his name. It doesn't
really matter. This is a,
a, an ideology that many
conservatives are saying,
"Look, it's been thirty and
forty years since the civil
rights movement. That's
enough time." And liberals
would say, "Ah, what about
the previous two hundred?"
Well, anyway, Sandra
Day O'Connor says,
"Yeah, we've
come a long way,
but we're still not perfect
as a society in this issue.
In twenty-five years--I
think about twenty-five
years is about right." How
she came up with a number,
I have no idea. "But
in twenty-five years,
it will probably be time to
revisit this question." And
you can bet, well before
twenty-five years is up I'm
sure, but if by some miracle
it's not challenged within
twenty-five years, you
better believe that there'll
be a twenty-fifth
anniversary of suits against
affirmative action,
and college admissions,
and, and wherever else
it's articulated. So the
University of Michigan law
school had to actually scrap
its policy. The University
of Michigan had a slightly
different policy that
supported affirmative action
in diversifying its
pop--student population,
was able to keep
it. Now collectively,
these cases demonstrate
how race works in a legal
setting since the civil
rights triumphs of the
1960s. Something
interesting has happened in
these cases, though.
In each of these cases,
white plaintiffs were the
ones who were filing suit,
claiming their equal rights
had been violated. This is
sort of the fascinating turn
in civil rights law,
equal protection law,
in the nineties, in the
eighties into the nineties.
Something that
was encouraged,
by the way, by
Clarence Thomas,
when he was the
head of the EEOC,
that became an
organization--it was put
there by Ronald Reagan--it
was an organization that
actually ended up becoming
non-functioning as far as
supporting claims for
racial discrimination,
ethnic discrimination, and
gender discrimination. The
backlog is tens of thousands
of cases. But we're in a
moment in the 1990s where
the equal protection clause
of, of the Fourteenth
Amendment is used often and
to great effect by
civil rights advocates
over--especially the height
of the movement in the
fifties and sixties--has now
a much narrower application
and is used with greater
success to roll back some of
the more controversial
gains of the civil rights
movement. So in a
sense, the civil,
civil rights laws are being
used against the policies
promulgated by civil rights
activism when you get into
the 1990s.
All of this
begs the question,
is, how race is used in our
society. This will really
be the lecture--the
topic of the final lecture,
but it's important to
understand the passions. I
mean, I've been talking
about them in sort of a
clinical way that you see
in Supreme Court cases,
federal court cases,
the last twenty or thirty
minutes. But the passion of
how people use and--use and
abuse race hasn't diminished
in the wake of the civil
rights
victories of the 1960s,
when the civil
rights excesses--again,
based on your
politics. In the 1970s,
for instance, in Boston,
Mass.--I already talked
about the Stuart case in
Boston in the nineties. But
Boston has a nasty history
when it comes to racial and
ethnic politics. White
ethnic communities in Boston
are up in arms. There's a
new policy about busing.
They were going to take
black kids in Boston--this
is a highly segregated
city--and bring them into,
quote "our schools" and
ship "our kids" out to black
schools. "This is an
atrocity." So you have
gangs of angry white ethnic
Bostonians attacking school
buses with children in them,
hurling epithets left and
right, and acting in the
most strug--disturbing kinds
of ways, when you think
about the politics of racial
symbolism and
citizenship. I mean,
these are some of the core
themes with which I began
this course.
Theodore Landsmark,
an African American man,
graduates from Yale with a
J.D.
in '73, a degree in
architecture in '76. Up in
Boston, he's
walking out of City Hall,
a well-dressed man,
three-piece suit,
very professional. At least
until recently--he still may
be--the
president of a, of a,
of an arts university in
Boston. He steps out into
the City Hall Plaza, unaware
that there is a mob of these
angry white ethnic
individuals upset about
busing policies. He's not
an activist as far as busing
is concerned.
He's not one of the,
the people on the front
lines calling for change,
but he is black. And that's
all that mattered to the
person who approached him
and expressed his idea about
citizenship
upon, or rather in,
Landsmark. Taking
the American flag,
with a fixed point, and
goring Landsmark. He
survives. He survives. But
if you're thinking that the
politics of
citizenship, and belonging,
and of racial
symbolism--wrapped up in
this case in just a black
man walking out of City
Hall--if you think those
were politics of a different
era, going back prior to
the sixties and fifties and
earlier--this is 1970s--and
if you think it's only
politics of the 1970s, I
think in the last lecture
we'll see that it's a
problem very much with us in
our "post-racial"
age. Thank you very much.